[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre à paris la sécurité
se dégrade de manière forte et rapide
depuis début 2010 9
les vols ont augmenté de 12% les
cambriolages de 8% et les violences
sexuelles de 5% pendant que la mairie de
paris et la préfecture de police se
renvoient la balle
ce sont les parisiens qui trinquent
aucun territoire parisien n'est
désormais épargner plus 51 % de vols
avec violence dans le 20e arrondissement
dans mon arrondissement le 16e
les cambriolages ont explosé avec 18 %
d'augmentation et 62%
oui ses pattes ouais 62 % de vols de
véhicules 100% de dégradations de
mobilier urbain dans le xème sont les
parisiens qui payent la facture
ça vous fait rire pas moi votre métier
ce n'est pas d'interpeller la société
c'est d'interpeller les délinquants et
je ne parle même pas de la crise des
gilets jaunes et de désagréments causés
au parisien il y a une spécificité
historique dans la capitale qui est que
les pouvoirs de police sont confiés non
pas aux mères nées au préfet de police
et vous ne devez pas que constater mais
agir
alors monsieur le ministre où en est on
de la réforme tant attendue de la
préfecture de police
la lutte contre la délinquance n'est pas
un sujet secondaire en termes de
doctrine sécuritaire je ne connaît que
deux mots la fermeté et le résultat